hello and welcome to this video playing
with fire tiger he's a new opponent good
rating so new canoe going on he's gotten
he's got tons of games so just a
coincidence that I have never never
played them so we have a declined banco
here with an early a form this is their
various versions of this position with a
for with quincy to it's um it's um
somewhat irritating at times the the
different versions but ok so i'm going
to try to trade here maybe 923 you can
avoid this trade and you can try a five
next something like that okay prepare
night a 62 b form
Queen asics might also be an option mmm
not quite sure if a queen trade would
help my cause doesn't look all that bad
actually creature is six if he castles
for examples looks very normal to Castle
I mean he can't avoid the Queen yeah but
come on what about about 94 was that's
not a move here because of b3 okay still
it's kind of a self pin here no b3 I can
take the rook actually all rights i'm
slow here so what can I not take I mean
okay I'm I'm really in a pin then maybe
this is the problem and I need to
prepare it okay let's prepare
and night if way it is a pretty awkward
self pin and now actually I think I'm
threatening night a for as after
whatever a play would be won't be a tie
and pin him with this night the
controversial position but it's a very
interesting i think i believe i should
be ok here would be quite surprised if
this is a bad position for black don't
don't know i also don't see a many
obvious moves for him yeah so what what
can he do like Bishop Bishop d2 hangs be
too or what is he playing here he covers
the Queen so this means that night c7
could be um on the cards so rugby eight
maybe him this was there is no tactic
here 96 or whatever know so route PA
that debt fields kind of logical anyway
and now I'm definitely threatening night
a four and he cannot play b3 still yeah
looks a little bit awkward for white yes
but I'm still I'm still having all the
all the spins going is night a form a
move 97 would actually cost the B to
pawn but what move doesn't cost the
beach coupon you can of course take what
this is a very nice position then for me
okay I can also drop the night back and
93 so this is the thing this is more
active so let's do it so Queen takes
I guess quinte exam taking queen a look
you can go Quincy to but I'm still
having huge pressure on the one the B
file yeah so night 85 yeah definitely or
not yes still-still I mean I'm having
all this pressure so let's do this first
and get every everybody in on a bishop
move i can go King evade or something
yeah okay be too when I can't he get his
giving me be to here and this position
it's there any reason not to take it
don't see it now I'm taking this so the
track looks normal and now let's see I
can't play f6 just like stopping this
mechanically on play in a more dynamic
way Rupe be one looks good though yeah
would be one is a good move I think this
tries to trade off the supporting rook
and if I get in Knight f6 I might just
win stuff this is also kind of kind of
weak the center now would be one I think
this was a good decision if I've now I
take you 1 and take if i take the pawn
on e5 okay maybe not a fascist sexa SSID
em okay taking us looks like the easiest
solution and now Knight to f6 I just
want to spawn
d 5 i'll take and take 35 taken t5 maybe
he will take with the night night takes
95 96 hmm yeah maybe i can go night
before as well this is also very
sensible looking option which is
actually threatening would be 12 pretty
serious threat yeah okay that does look
quite good rugby one he has no bishop
move because bishop g1 will end in a
check made I think it's a check made if
not it's a very strong attack at least
okay so he prevented this um what now
see having some kind of active idea
night see to wear so I'm going to cover
this okay so this is once to go around
here or something Ruby to work with to
us actually good I think threatening
look a two and if he moves the night I
go to be 10 graduate time morning it
must be awkward unless he Oh his miracle
miracle chess but i have lost a miracle
chest quite often so what's going on
here Knight c3
shoot this is actually somewhat
dangerous okay let me play this first if
I take this a 7 this is actually really
promoting unbelievable and what what
what what what nonsense hey what what
what is happening here I really I really
do know sometimes I want to totally
clean win and I screw it up now I've got
three seconds check check black for FX
on time what kind of nonsense oh my god
Bishop be six year from this position oh
my god I mean okay this is really pretty
unbelievable we should have two is
already made almost I just think okay he
resides I mean II ok this is this also
doesn't work but it's like what so what
does winbush should be 3 is like minus a
million yeah there should be a win but I
didn't see it I just didn't see this is
threatening medium this is the problem
this is a threat Shang made that is
actually very easy okay I cannot take
there's a seven and this
it should be three is always winning and
this is also an idea for still wins but
by now I was totally confused and why
don't I take here actually this is also
still simply sometimes i really get
totally irritated when my opponent plays
this kind of desperate last shots move
and I'll occur and this is like winning
a million times even this end game is
better for black goodbye now I was
totally unnerved yeah the whole game was
yeah what can you say it just got
totally killed what can you say yeah I'm
fine and after 94 leg just has a
strategically winning position Shack I
think I did a decent job they actually
this is makes it all the more annoying
because he had absolutely zero chance in
this game absolutely not a single threat
the whole game and then this this should
be six nonsense i am getting so
irritated yeah we should be three wins
whatever everything winds but i didn't
find it i was also thinking this but
yeah the key is always if you ask the
engine this is threatening mate Bishop
f4 is mate this is the problem he just
gets chick made it here I wanted to play
for made but this is this was so
irritating and it's hard for me to get
rid of this if I would I would easily be
close to 2500 all the time really easily
okay thanks for watching